TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this week I'm coming to
you from the Firebase Dev
Summit in Amsterdam.
Here's your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
The Android 8.1
Developer Preview
is now available and includes
a set of targeted enhancements
including optimizations for
Android Go and a new Neural
Networks API to accelerate
on-device machine intelligence.
We've also included a few
smaller enhancements to Oreo
in response to user
and developer feedback.
All the details are on the
post linked in the description
below.
Android Studio 3.0
is a large update
focused on accelerating your
app development on Android,
and it's ready to
download today.
Head on over to the
post for details, video,
and screenshots, covering
everything that's
new with Android Studio 3.0.
Go 1.8 introduces library,
runtime, performance,
and security
improvements, and it's now
generally available for
the Google App Engine
standard environment.
The Gmail add-ons
framework, which
we previewed earlier
this year, is now
available to all
developers, and it
lets you integrate
your app into Gmail
and extend Gmail to
handle quick actions.
A video and links to the
docs, and a code lab,
are on the post.
Our post for Chrome
63 Beta is out
and covers dynamic module
imports, async iterators
and generators, device memory
API, and permissions UI
changes.
All the details and
code are on the post.
After years of interviewing
Google Cloud Platform
customers, product managers,
engineers, developer experts,
salespeople, support
staff, and more,
the "Google Cloud
Platform Podcast"
has released their
100th episode.
Congratulations, Francesc
and Mark and the whole
podcast team from all of us
over here at "The Dev Show."
In episode one of "Build
Out," Colt and Reto
go head to head presenting
competing system architecture
designs for a smart garden.
The restriction-- they
must use the Tasks API.
Check out the first episode
of "Build Out" with the link
in the description below.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
Thanks for joining me here at
the Firebase Dev Summit 2017.
You can catch links to all the
videos from all the sessions
here in the description below.
I'm Timothy Jordan for
"The Developer Show."
See you next time.